THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER* BATH.
BONTA.
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DAILY DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON.
GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE.
LIMON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA RAMOS RAY IS THREE
OF US ROBERT REAVIS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK THAT OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN.
DOCTOR CHAT.
IT IS HUMAN NATURE TO ONLY WANT
TO LISTEN TO THOSE WITH WHOM WE
AGREE.
THAT'S ONLY GIVE HONOR TO THOSE
WITH LIKE MINDED INDIVIDUALS.
BUT WE OPEN OURSELVES UP TO
HEARING THE WISDOM THAT OTHERS
HOLD.
WE BECOME ENRICHED.
AND WE TREAT OTHERS WITH THE
HONOR THAT WE DESIRE.
WE BECOME TELEVISION BY OUR
ACTIONS.
MAYBE ONLY ONE A BLESSING GRAND
AS THE HUMIDITY LEARN FROM
OTHERS.
AND THE WISDOM TO HONOR ALL.
WHOM WE ENCOUNTER [inaudible]
A MAN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER MEDINA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SALUTING OUR
NATION'S FLAG READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
BY.
SE SOMEWHERE.
IN THIS AREA --
WHICH IS AND WHY --
IS A LITTLE.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JANUARY TENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT NINE A.
M. ON WILL KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHEAP CLICKY DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE ROLL WAS CALLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS MOVED TO
CORN CALL THE ASSEMBLY MOTION
CARRIED TIME NINE OH FIVE AM.
SPEAKER PRETENDER TO THE SURGEON
OUR MISSILES OR GIPSON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
AT THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER BONTA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS KILEY WEBER AND WICKS.
TO HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
I FOR THE REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOPER.
MAYES NAZARIAN RAMOS SMITH AND
THREE OF US TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER
WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF GAS WITH US IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY.
WE HAVE A NUMBER SPECIAL GUESTS
HERE TODAY I AM GOING TO FIRST
RECOGNIZE.
MR KILEY MISTER KILEY AS GUESTS
TODAY AND MR KILEY WILL BE
INTRODUCING THOSE GAS FROM MY
DESK IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER
[inaudible]
MR KILEY [inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
MR KILEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
INTRODUCE SOPHIA BARTON OF
ELDORADO HILLS THIS AFTERNOON.
SOFIA IS A WORLD RECOGNIZED
CHAMPION IN THE SPORT OF BATON
TWIRLING.
AND I INVITED HER HERE TODAY TO
CELEBRATE HER ACHIEVEMENTS.
THIS PAST SUMMER SOPHIA
PARTICIPATED IN THE SIXTY EIGHT
U. S. NATIONALS WHERE SHE WAS A
GOLD MEDAL WINNER ALONG WITH A
NUMBER OF OTHER ACCOLADES IN
INDIVIDUAL COMPETITION.
IN ADDITION TO ARE INDIVIDUAL
EVENTS SOVIET IS ALSO A MEMBER
OF TWO TEAMS THE REVOLUTION
SMALL PER TWIRLING TEAM PLACE
SECOND OVERALL AT NATIONALS AND
THE REVOLUTION LARGE SWIRLING
TEAM.
PLACED FIRST.
THIS PAST SUMMER SOPHIA ALSO
PARTICIPATED IN THE THIRTY
FOURTH WORLD CHAMPIONSHIPS ALONG
WITH NEARLY TWO HUNDRED ATHLETES
FROM FIFTEEN COUNTRIES.
THERE WERE THIRTY FIVE JUNIOR
ATHLETES COMPETING IN THE JUNIOR
WOMEN'S FREESTYLE EVENT AND
AFTER THREE FREESTYLE
PERFORMANCES SOVIET PLACED
SEVENTH.
IN THE WORLD.
IN ADDITION TO BEING A WORLD
CHAMPION BATON POOR ALSO TWIRLER
SO BE IS ALSO INTERCEDE NEW YEAR
AT OAK RIDGE HIGH SCHOOL IN
ELDORADO HILLS WHERE SHE SOMEHOW
FINDS THE TIME TO MAINTAIN A
FOUR POINT.
TWO FIVE WITH FOUR POINT ONE TWO
FIVE GPA END AS A VARSITY SOCCER
AND CLUB LEVEL SOCCER PLAYER.
I'M TOLD BY HER COACHES BUT
SHE'S ALWAYS THE FIRST ONE TO
ARRIVE AT THE GYM AND THE LAST
TO LEAVE.
NOT ONLY IS SHE DEDICATED AND
HARD WORKING HER SPORTSMANSHIP
MAKES ARE A GREAT ROLE MODEL FOR
ALL ATHLETES TODAY SHE'S
ACCOMPANIED BY HER FAMILY HER
COACH KELLY PERLMAN.
AND CALIFORNIA BATON COUNCIL
PRESIDENT CHRISTINE RODRIGUEZ
PLEASE JOIN ME IN CONGRATULATING
SOPHIA ON HER INCREDIBLE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY MEMBERS
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER
MEDINA MISTER MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE TODAY TO RECOGNIZE
FEBRUARY FOURTH.
THROUGH FEBRUARY EIGHTH.
AS NATIONAL SCHOOL COUNSELING
WEEK.
SCHOOL COUNSELORS ACTIVELY
COMMIT TO HELP STUDENTS EXPLORE
THEIR ABILITY STRENGTHS.
AND INTERESTS AND THEY ALSO HELP
STUDENTS ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND
PLAN FOR A CAREER.
TODAY IT IS MY HONOR TO
INTRODUCE JOSH GOOD DEMUS.
SEEDED ABOVE IN THE GALLERY A
MAN THAT IS COMMITTED DEDICATED
AND ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS.
JOSH IS A SCHOOL COUNSELOR AT
CENTENNIAL HIGH SCHOOL AND THE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN DONALD
HAYES OUTSTANDING SCHOOL
COUNSELOR OF THE YEAR.
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS.
DURING HIS TIME AT CENTENNIAL
HIGH SCHOOL JOSH'S WORKED WITH
HIS TEAM. TO ENHANCE DATA
GATHERING AND ANALYZE PROCESSES
IN ADDITION TO OVERSEEING THE
COUNSELING PROGRAMS CORE
CURRICULUM FOR SENIORS.
MISTER GIDDINESS HAS
RESTRUCTURED AND REIMAGINE THE
SENIOR EXIT PROCESS BY PROVIDING
A ONE TO ONE POST SECONDARY
PLANNING MEETING WITH A SCHOOL
COUNSELOR.
IN ORDER TO VALIDATE THAT EVERY
SENIOR HAS AN EFFECTIVE PLAN.
LAST YEAR MR GIDDINESS
SUCCESSFULLY CREATED THE FIRST
EVER.
CENTENNIAL SIGNING DAY AN EVENT
TO CELEBRATE SENIORS AND THEIR
PLAN POSTSECONDARY JOURNEY.
MR GIDDINESS POSSESSES A NATURAL
TALENT AND GENUINE INTEREST.
IN THE BEST OUTCOME FOR IS
STUDENTS.
HIS DEDICATION HAS IMMENSELY
BENEFITTED THE YOUNG PEOPLE
DEPEND ON PROFESSIONALS LIKE HIM.
MEMBERS IT IS MY HONOR TO SHARE
WITH YOU AND WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA JOSH GOOD EUNICE
PLEASE HELP.
ME AND WELCOME IN HERE TO THE
FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY THANK YOU.
AND MISTER MEDINA YOU HAVE A
SECOND INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AGAIN IT IS MY HONOR TO
RISE. TO HONOR PAUL BRITNEY YOU.
ALSO SEATED IN THE GALLERY.
WHO IS THE RECIPIENT OF THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL STEWARD LEADER AWARD?
POVERTY NEAL IS A NATIVE TO THE
INLAND EMPIRE WHICH I REPRESENT.
AND WAS BORN AND RAISED IN
REDLANDS.
PAUL RECEIVED HIS BACHELOR OF
ARTS IN CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SAMBAR MEDINA.
AND A MASTER OF DIVINITY FROM ST
JOHN'S SEMINARY AND CAMERI YOU.
PAUL SITS ON NUMEROUS BOARDS
INCLUDING THE INLAND EMPIRE
ECONOMIC PARTNERSHIP RESEARCH AS
PRESIDENT AND CEO WHICH HAS A
VISION FOR BETTER IN THE QUALITY
OF LIFE.
AND BUSINESS CLIMATE OF
RIVERSIDE AND SAN BENITO COUNTY.
HE'S A PAST BOARD MEMBER AND
PAST CHAIR OF ABILITY.
TWENTY ONE A COALITION THAT
BRINGS TOGETHER THE PUBLIC
BUSINESSES AND COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS TO PURSUE REGIONAL
SOLUTIONS TO THE TRANSPORTATION
CHALLENGES THAT FACE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
HE ALSO SERVES ON THE BOARD AND
IS PAST CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STEWARDSHIP NETWORK.
WHICH DEVELOPS IN A VOTER
INNOVATIVE REGIONAL SOLUTIONS TO
THE STATE'S MOST PRESSING
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENTAL AND
COMMUNITY CHALLENGE.
ALL HAS BEEN A REMARKABLE AND
EFFECTIVE VOICE FOR THE INLAND
EMPIRE.
IT HAS BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK
WITH THEM ANY IS CHAMPION TO
EXPAND ITS SKILLED WORKFORCE AND
TO PROVE EDUCATIONAL ACCESS.
ENTERTAINMENT.
THIS AWARD IS FITTING BECAUSE
PAUL MODEL --
SHIP LOOKS LIKE MEMBERS PLEASE
HELP ME AND WELCOMING PADRE NEAR
TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY.
AMOS MEDINA I WOULD LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER FROM
MY DESK FOR A VERY SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION ON THE FLOOR.
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK
YOU JOIN WITH ME TODAY TO
WELCOME CONGRESSMAN GABBY
GIFFORDS TO OUR CHAMBERS.
OBVIOUS PLEDGE HER LIFE TO
SERVICE.
FIRST SERVING IN THE ARIZONA
LEGISLATURE FOR FIVE YEARS THEN
BECOME THE THIRD WOMAN FROM
ARIZONA TO SERVE IN THE UNITED
STATES HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
HER TIME IN THIS ROSE
IRREVOCABLY CUT SHORT WHEN ON
JANUARY EIGHTH.
TWENTY ELEVEN WHILE ATTENDING A
CONSTITUENT EVENTS.
CONGRESS ON THE CORNER AT A
LOCAL SAFEWAY.
SHE WAS SHOT IN THE HEAD BY A
GUNMAN WHO OPENED FIRE ON THE
CROWD. NINETEEN WERE INJURED.
SIX WERE TRAGICALLY KILLED.
GABBY RESIGNED FROM CONGRESS AND
BEGIN A PROCESS OF LIFELONG
RECOVERY.
AND THEN THE NEW TOWN SHOOTING
SHOOTING HAPPENED. TWENTY FIVE
AND SIX YEAR OLDS WERE KILLED
ALONG WITH SIX EDUCATORS.
GABBY'S COMMITMENT TO SERVICE
TOOK ON NEW MEANING.
AND SHE COMMITTED HER LIFE'S
WORK TO ENDING THE SENSELESS GUN
VIOLENCE THAT HAS PLAGUED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS OUR COUNTRY.
IT WAS THEN THAT I FIRST MET
GABBY.
WE WERE WORKING TO PASS THE
FEDERAL UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS BILL.
WELL THIS BILL DIDN'T PASS.
A MOVEMENT BEGAN.
AND THE FACE OF THAT MOVEMENT
WAS NONE OTHER THAN GABBY
GIFFORDS.
SINCE NEW TOWN OVER THREE
HUNDRED LAWS HAVE BEEN ENACTED
AT THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP KEEP
GUNS OUT OF THE WRONG HANDS
[inaudible]
GABBY PERSONIFIES COURAGE.
SHE HER HUSBAND NAVY VETERAN
ASTRONAUT CAPTAIN MARK KELLY AND
THE ENTIRE TEAM AT GIFFORD'S
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER.
ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED
AND HUMBLED TO WELCOME MY
FRIENDS.
THE HONORABLE GABBY GIFFORDS TO
OUR ASSEMBLY FLOOR
MEMBERS WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS IN THE
CHAMBER.
MR A QUIRK.
MR QUIRK YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE
CHAMBER.
SUPPORT FOR YOUR INTRODUCTION
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ART TODAY ABOVE ME TO THE LEFT
IF THEY WOULD PLEASE STAND.
I RISE IN RECOGNITION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY.
THE C. C. S. T. WAS CREATED
THIRTY YEARS AGO VIA AN ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
WHICH CALLED ON THE CREATION OF
THE COUNCIL TO BE OF SERVICE TO
THE GOVERNOR THE LEGISLATURE AND
OTHER STATE ENTITIES.
ON MATTERS INVOLVING SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY --
THEY HAVE WORKED FOR MANY YEARS
NOW ON VARIOUS REPORTS ON
EVERYTHING FROM --
CLIMATE CHANGE TO THE HEALTH OF
OUR OCEANS.
BEYONCE BEYOND THESE RESEARCH
PROJECTS THE CCSD ARE MANY OF
YOU KNOW SPONSORS SCIENCE
FELLOWS.
WHICH YOU HAVE BEEN COMING NOW
FOR ABOUT TEN YEARS AND HAVE
DONE EXCELLENT WORK AND MANY OF
WHOM OF ARE NOW --
WORKING IN EITHER GOVERNMENT
OFFICES OR IN THE LEGISLATURE.
OUR THIS WORK THIS WEEK IS --
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY WEEK AT
THE CAPITOL.
OUR RECEPTION IS --
THIS EVENING CELEBRATING SIGN
INFORMING POLICY.
IS GOING TO BE HELD AT FIVE TO
SIX THIRTY AT THE MAX AND I'LL
BE THERE.
I SCIENCE TRANS LATER SHOWCASE
ON WEDNESDAY AT ONE IN THE
CAPITOL BASEMENT FEATURING
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND POSTDOCS.
OF FROM YOUR DISTRICTS SHARING
THEIR POLICY RELEVANT --
RESEARCH --
THE RELEASE OF AN UPDATED REPORT
DETAILING THE ECONOMIC AND
POLICY IMPACTS OF FEDERAL
LABORATORY RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AN EXPERT BRIEFING ON EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES FOR REAL TIME
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRES WILL BE
HELD THURSDAY AT NOON.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
TODAY THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL IN
SCIENCE TECHNOLOGY.
THIS WEEK OF ACTIVITIES WILL
HELP US ALL LEARN MORE ABOUT THE
MULTITUDE OF WAYS SCIENCES AT
OUR SERVICE EVERY WEEK HERE IN
THE CAPITAL WITH.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON
SCIENCE AND TECHNOLOGY.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
FORMER ASSEMBLY WOMAN PATTY
LOPEZ HAS JOINED US IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER.
FORMER SAN THE WOMAN OF HAS.
AND DOCTOR WEBER.
YOU HAVE GUESTS IN THE CHAMBERS
TODAY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE IT IS MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE AND WELCOME DOCTOR
PAUL LET BROWN HINES TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY --
TOMORROW DOCTOR BROWN HINES WILL
BECOME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
DOCTOR BROWN HINES RECEIVED HER
BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN ENGLISH
LITERATURE FROM CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY SAMPOERNA.
CHARTER MASTER'S AND DOCTORATE
DEGREES IN ENGLISH LITERATURE
WITH AN EMPHASIS IN AFRICAN
AMERICAN LITERATURE AND CULTURE
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE WHERE SHE
CURRENTLY SERVES AS A PROFESSOR.
DR BROUGHT BROWN HANDS IS THE
PUBLISHER OF BLACK VOICES NEWS
AND THE FOUNDER OF THE VOICE
MEDIA VENTURES.
DOCTOR BROWN HINES ALSO SERVES
AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AFRICAN AMERICAN CAUCUS AND
COUNTLESS OTHER COMMUNITY
SERVICE BOARDS.
JUST TO NAME A FEW SHE'S A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
THE COMMUNITY FOUNDATION INLAND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PRESS FOUNDATION.
IN LAND THE INSTITUTE AND THE
FORTUNES IN FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND YOUNG WOMEN
EVERYWHERE.
I HAVE TO ALSO SAY THAT SHE IS
OF COURSE THE DAUGHTER OF A
FORMER MEMBER SURE --
BROWN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SURE BROWN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING DR
PAULETTE BROWN HINES THAT
CALIFORNIA'S THING WITH.
STATUS
.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE.
WE ARE MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE IS A C. R..
FIFTEEN CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER CHEN
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA THAT THIS WEEK.
DOCTOR CHEN ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ACR
FIFTEEN IF YOU'RE A FIFTEEN WILL
RECOGNIZE THE WEEK OF FEBRUARY
THIRD AND THREE NINE TWENTY
NINETEEN AS CALIFORNIA FITNESS
WEEK.
CALIFORNIA AND FORTUNE RANKS
FORTY SEVENTH IN THE NATION FOR
ADULT WILL BE SEATED CURRENT
OBESITY RATES IN CALIFORNIA ARE
AT 25%.
OFF FROM 18% IN TWO THOUSAND AND
9% IN NINETEEN NINETY IN.
THE CAL FOR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STATES THAT OVER 50%
OF CALIFORNIA CHILDREN ARE NOT
PHYSICALLY FIT.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO EDUCATE THE YOUTH AND ADULTS
ON THE HARMFUL EFFECTS OF
IMPROPER NUTRITION AND ACTIVITY --
AND WITH THAT --
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU --
MISTER SPEAKER RESPECT WE ASK
FOR AYE VOTE MASS AT THE FIRST
ROLL CALL YOU OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHEN MISTER
GIBSON YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE JOINT
AUTHOR OF ACR FIFTEEN WHICH
PROCLAIMS THIS WEEK ASK FITNESS
WEEK.
IT IS NO SECRET THAT OUR STATE
IS EXPERIENCING UNPRECEDENTED
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA MORE THAN SEVEN
MILLION ADULTS AND ADOLESCENTS.
ARE OBESE OBESITY IS ONLY
GETTING WORSE.
ALTHOUGH ITS PREVALENCE IN
OBESITY AND HIGH IS HIGH AMONG
ALL CALIFORNIA'S IT IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING THE
POOR AND PEOPLE OF COLOR.
OBESITY IS NOT ONLY DANGEROUS
PUBLIC HEALTH IT IS ALSO VERY
EXPENSIVE RESEARCH SHOW THAT
MEDICAL CARE ASSOCIATE IT WITH.
SEVERE OBESITY COSTS OUR STATE
BILLIONS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
AS A STATE WE MUST PURSUE POLICY
CHANGES THAT PROMOTES POSITIVE
DIETARY AND PHYSICAL ACTIVITY.
MISTER SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK BUT I VOTE ON ACR AND THINK
THE A MEMBER FROM YORBA LINDA
FOR BRINGING THIS BEFORE THE
BODY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GIBSON.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION DOCTOR CHANCE
ASKING THAT THE FIRST ROLE WE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THIS RESOLUTION CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
NEVER SYSTEMS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C.
R..
FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE A ROLE THERE ARE SEVENTY
ONE CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE.
ON THIS RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MEMBERS DOCTOR CHAN WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE HIS COLLEAGUES.
TO JOIN HIM THIS THURSDAY.
BEFORE FLOOR SESSION. FOR A MEET
AND GREET WITH CROSSFIT
PERSONALITY.
BROOKE ENDS IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON'S.
OFFICE.
THAT'S THURSDAY BEFORE FLOOR
SESSION IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIBSON'S OFFICE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO MEET CROSSFIT
PERSONALITY BROOKE [inaudible]
ENDS.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWO ACR.
SIXTEEN OPERATE.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND OTHERS A RELATIVE TO
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR CELEBRATION.
MR CHIU YOU MAIL IN.
SENATE CANNOT.
SING NEED YOUNG HE GUNG HAY FAT
CHOY TOOK MONOMOY.
HAPPY LUNAR NEW YEAR EVERYONE.
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES AS
CHAIR OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND REPRESENTATIVE FOR
THE OLDEST CHINATOWN IN THE
COUNTRY.
IT IS MY HONOR TO PRESENT ACR
SIXTEEN IN RECOGNITION OF LUNAR
NEW YEAR.
LUNAR NEW YEAR BEGINS TOMORROW
ON COME THE YEAR OF THE PIG.
THE YEAR OF THE PIG MARKS THE
LAST YEAR OF THE TWELVE YEARS OD
X. CYCLE.
BUT THIS YEAR IS THE FIRST YEAR
THAT LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED AS A DAY
OF SPECIAL SIGNIFICANCE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AS A RESULT OF SB EIGHT NINETY
TWO WHICH PASSED AND WAS SIGNED
LAST YEAR. TOO MANY ASIAN
AMERICANS IN OUR STATE.
LUNAR NEW YEAR IS ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT HOLIDAYSOF THE
YEAR.
AS MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS MY
FAMILY INCLUDED.
SPEND QUALITY TIME TOGETHER TO
CELEBRATE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF
THE TRADITIONS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE NEW YEAR.
ON YOUR DESK YOU WILL FIND A
TANGERINE.
TANGERINES AND ORANGES ARE
SYMBOLIC IN ASIAN CULTURES GIVEN
AS A GESTURE OF GOODWILL.
THE ROUND SHAPE OF THE MANDARIN
SIGNIFIES FAMILY UNITY AND ITS
GOLDEN COLOR REPRESENTS WEALTH.
MANY OF YOU TODAY ARE WEARING
RED.
IN ADDITION TO SUPPORTING THE GO
READ CAMPAIGN.
RED IS THE COLOR OF CELEBRATION
IN MANY OF OUR ASIAN CULTURES.
YOU ALSO HAVE ON YOUR DESK A RED
ENVELOPE.
WHICH ARE GIVEN TO CHILDREN AND
UNMARRIED ADULTS CONTAINING
MONEY FOR GOOD LUCK.
AND IN CASE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ARE WONDERING THE
ENVELOPES IN YOUR DESK DO NOT
CONTAIN MONEY.
BUT THEY DO CONTAIN FESTIVE
HOLIDAY CANDY WHICH ARE
IMPRINTED WITH THE CHARACTERS
FOR FORTUNE AND WEALTH.
AS WE WOULD BRING IN THE YEAR OF
THE PIG I HOPE THAT ALL OF YOU
WILL JOIN THE LOCAL FESTIVITIES
IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
CELEBRATIONS THAT ILLUSTRATE OUR
STATE RICH CULTURAL HISTORY AND
DIVERSITY.
I ALSO HOPE THAT THIS EVENING
YOU'LL JOIN THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AT FIVE O'CLOCK IN ROOM.
TWO THREE SEVENTEEN FOR OUR KICK
OFF THE FESTIVITIES JOIN US FOR
THE LUNAR NEW YEAR RECEPTION.
AND I DO HOPE THAT TODAY YOU
WILL JOIN OUR CAUCUS IN WISHING
EVERY CALIFORNIA.
A HEALTHY AND PROSPEROUS NEW
YEAR BY VOTING AYE ON IS YOUR
SIXTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER TRUE MISTER
KANSEN CHU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER.
ID ARE A RUSH TO SUPPORT ACR.
SIXTEEN OF THE CHINESE LUNAR NEW
YEAR IS A MOST CELEBRATED A
FASHIONABLE IN THE CHINESE
VIETNAMESE AND KOREAN.
COMMUNITY.
I HAVE OUT AS MOST REPEAT RECENT
IMMIGRANT OF A CHINESE DESCENT.
I'M VERY HAPPY AND HONORED TO
CELEBRATE THIS NEW YEAR'S ALL.
FORTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN WITH MY
COLLEAGUES.
AND IN THE CAPITAL.
THE YOU KNOW NEW YORK NEW YORK
OF THE STATE OF FASHIONABLE
STARTED --
BACK AND FOURTEEN SEVEN FULL
FORTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
ADD THIS IS REALLY A TIME. FOR A
PEOPLE TO GET TOGETHER AFTER A
HARSH OF THE WEATHER SEASON.
AND THE VILLAGE TO GET TOGETHER
TO PLAN FOR THEIR OF NEXT YEAR'S
CROP.
SO I WANTED TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CONGRATULATE ALL
OF THE SINCE.
I WISH YOU ALL HAVE A VERY GOOD
A BILL PACKAGE FILLED WITH THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA BE OF
BENEFIT BILLY A SIGNIFICANTLY
FOR YEARS.
AND AND ALSO FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ALIKE TO WISH THEM A
VERY PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR.
BECAUSE STUDY WILL CONTRIBUTE
MORE TO OUR OF OF COFFERS AND
AND AND AND YOU'VE DE.
I AM I AM --
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY IN AND OUT --
IF ALLOW ME TO SAY THAT IN
CHINESE WAS A SENIOR IN HIGH
LOOK HIM IN TO BE ENEMIES WITH
EIGHT TREMONT NORMALLY.
AS WELL AS THE SANCTUARY DR CHOI
IN KOREAN WAS SAY SAY HOME BOWL
Mà HEY.
BOB THE SALE.
REGULAR MUCH GLAUCIAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
DOCTOR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
SO YOU MAY AFFIRM WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD.
THANK YOU SPEAKER I ALSO --
RISE IN SUPPORT OF WHAT IS HE ON
SIXTEEN IN CELEBRATION OF LUNAR.
NEW YEAR THE LUNAR NEW YEAR IS
ON IMPORTANT FAMILY DAYS THE
HOLIDAY THAT IS CELEBRATED BY
MOST OF LAW.
THE ASIAN THE COUNTRIES
INCLUDING KOREA --
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE DAYS IN
AMERICA AS WE DO NOW --
IN KOREA IT IS SUCH A TIME WHEN
WE ARE ON OUR A WAR --
ELDERS.
AND THE AND OUR ANCESTORS SO
THROUGH --
SAY BAY --
BEING THAT BIG FOLLOW AND THEN
ALSO --
EXCHANGING GIFT IS GIVE GIFTS
AND ALL THE FAMILIES SO --
SCATTERED --
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IT WILL
GATHER A WHICH CREE THIS.
THE CHILDREN ARE GIVEN --
GIFT SO CALLED DOES HAVE ITS OWN
WHEN THEY BY --
ON THE FLOOR OF THE POWER TO OUR
ELDERS AND THE PARENTS.
AND THE I GUESS SO CHINESE SO
CULTURE IS SO AGAIN NOT HANDING
OUT THE THE MONEY IN THE ARE.
RATHER HIGH AND THE LOW.
AND THEN I E. OF FONDA
[inaudible]
OF NINETY NINE HUNDRED NINE NINE
CENTS SO FULL FORM HERE INSIDE
THE THANK YOU.
THAT THE TRADITION S. ARE SHARED
BY GUESTS ARE BY MANY CULTURES
SO.
UP WITH THIS ARE.
A NEW.
OUR NO NOT YEAR --
BEING DOT THE OF OF OF PICK UP
BUT OF PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
THIS IS A SPECIAL.
YEAR OF THE PIG.
GOLDEN PICK UP.
WHICH IS SAW W. YA --
ASSURING THE PLASTI YEAR SO IN
THE SPIRIT OF A LUNA IO THIS
YEAR.
NARROW SO REACH OUT.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE AS CHANGE THE
TO ASA AND TO SEEK OUT THE NEW
LIFE A AND A CLEAN SLATE ALSO
THAT THOUGHT WE CAN ENJOY A YEAR.
OF A NEW BEGINNING SO.
SO IT IS.
WITH THE THOUGHT THEN THE SPIRIT
THAT I SAY. TO HAVE.
PALM MONEY BY THE SALE MORE.
PROPOSAL PRONUNCIATION AND THUS
IN YOUNG CHRYSLER.
DODGE SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE BLACK CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A C. R..
SIXTEEN IT IS ALWAYS A PLEASURE
TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES IN THOSE
AROUND THE WORLD AS WE CELEBRATE
THE LUNAR YOU IN NEW YEAR.
THE CELEBRATIONS PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEMONSTRATE THE
RICHNESS OF CHINESE CULTURE AND
TO CELEBRATE THE DIVERSITY OF
THE MANY CULTURES REPRESENTED IN
THIS GREAT STATE.
WE HAVE THE UNIQUE PRIVILEGE OF
A DIVERSE AND SPIRITED ASIAN
AMERICAN POPULATION THAT HAS AND
CONTINUES TO LEAVE ITS MARK ON
THIS STATE AND ON OUR COUNTRY.
TWENTY NINETEEN IS THE YEAR OF
THE PIG SYMBOLIZING WEALTH AND
FORTUNE SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
SAID ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
BUT THE PIG IS ALSO AN
EMBODIMENT OF DILIGENCE KINDNESS
AND GENERATION GENEROSITY ALL
VERY SOLID PROGRESSIVE VALUES.
THE YEAR AHEAD OF US WILL COME
WITH CHALLENGES BUT I AM HOPEFUL
THAT OUR BUDGET AND POLICIES
WILL BE A REFLECTION OF EXACTLY
THOSE QUALITIES [inaudible]
DILIGENCE KINDNESS AND
GENEROSITY TO THOSE WHO DON'T
YET SHARE IN CALIFORNIA'S WEALTH
AND GOOD FORTUNE.
IT IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT I
SUPPORT ACR SIXTEEN AND I WISH
US ALL A VERY HAPPY AND
PROSPEROUS NEW YEAR XIN NIAN
QUAI Là.
THANK YOU MISS KAMLAGER-DOVE
MINS KALRA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I WANNA
THANK OUR COLLEAGUE FROM CENSUS
CO CHAIR THE PILOTS IN THE
CAUCUS.
OPERATOR TO SING ACR.
SIXTEEN AND CERTAINLY WANT TO
WISH ALL CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
THOSE IN SAN JOSE A VERY VERY
HAPPY THE NEW YEAR --
WE HAVE -- A
LONG TIME UP ACTIVE CREAN
COMMUNITY WE ONE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING COMMUNITIES WE HAVE IS
OUR CHINESE COMMUNITY AND OF
COURSE --
WERE FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE
THE LARGEST BEATING IN SAN JOSE --
OVER THE WEEKEND --
BALL CELEBRATING A LITTLE SAIGON
YOU CAN DEFINITELY TELL THE
CELEBRATIONS ARE UNDER WAY --
IF YOU DON'T BRING EARPLUGS WHEN
YOU GO TO THESE HERE
CELEBRATIONS YOU'LL HEAR A LOT
OF FIRECRACKERS THAT GO OFF AND
IS DEFINITELY JOYOUS AND AND TO
SEE SO MANY FAMILIES ARE OUT
THERE --
CELEBRATING IN ADVANCE OF LUNAR
NEW YEAR AND AND CELEBRATIONS
WILL CONTINUE IN THE WEEKENDS I
HAD SO I ENCOURAGE ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO FIND SOME IN YOUR
OWN COMMUNITY WHETHER THEY'RE
CHINESE VIETNAMESE KOREAN OR ALL
THE ABOVE --
TO CELEBRATE WITH YOUR COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY SOMETHING
THAT WE GET TO ENJOY BEING
CALIFORNIAN THAT SO MANY OTHER
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD DON'T --
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE SO
MANY CULTURES AND HERITAGES AND
TO BE ABLE TO BE WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT I THINK WE NEED NOW.
MORE THAN EVER.
AND SO I AND WE CAN ALSO TAKE
THE RED ENVELOPES AND AND FIND
CHILDREN OR UNMARRIED ADULTS
LIKE MYSELF --
TO TO HAND THEM TO OF WHICH GOOD
FORTUNE IN THE YEAR AHEAD
[inaudible]
ANYWAY.
I JUST LIKE TO WISH EVERYONE
HAPPY NEW YEAR ITCH AMONG THE
MONEY.
XINGJIAN KYLA.
I THANK YOU MEMBERS MISTER KALRA
APPRECIATE YOUR GENEROSITY
[inaudible]
MR.
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE ON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA JEWISH.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AYE RICE ON
OF THE START OF THE OWNER NEW
YEAR.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY SIX
MILLION ASIAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICANS MANY OF WHOM
WILL MARK THE BEGINNING OF THE
LUNAR NEW YEAR TOMORROW ON
FEBRUARY FIFTH.
THE STORY OF THE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN CALIFORNIA IS A
LONG AND IMPRESSIVE LEGACY OF
STANDING UP TO DISCRIMINATION.
PERSEVERING AND OF ADDING THEIR
VALUABLE CULTURES TO THE MELTING
POT OF THIS GREAT STATE.
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HAS
CONTRIBUTED TO THE SOCIAL
CULTURAL CIVIC.
ECONOMIC AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
AND THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THE BREADTH OF COMMUNITIES
CELEBRATING THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
ILLUSTRATES THE STATE'S RICH
CULTURAL HISTORY AND COMMITMENT
TO RACIAL RELIGIOUS AND CULTURAL
DIVERSITY.
AND EVEN THOUGH THIS YEAR WE
CELEBRATE THE YEAR OF THE PIG.
I THINK IT'S KOSHER TO SEND ALL
THE BEST WISHES OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS.
ON BEHALF OF THE JEWISH CAUCUS I
WISH THOSE CELEBRATING LUNAR NEW
YEAR A YEAR OF GOOD HEALTH
PROSPERITY SUCCESS JUSTICE AND
PEACE [inaudible]
DAVIS BERMAN.
MR DEEP IN YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
IDEA OF FIRST WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING MY COLLEAGUE FROM A SAN
FRANCISCO OF FOR HIS GENEROSITY
IN INVITING ME TO CO SPONSOR
THIS RESOLUTION --
WITH HIM AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE
IN --
REINFORCING THE FACT THAT I
SHOULD SAY SOMETHING THE TODAY
ON THIS MATTER MISTER SPEAKER --
I WANT TO SHARE WITH WITH ALL OF
YOU -- MY
HISTORY AND WHAT IT MEANS TO BE.
A VIETNAMESE AMERICAN OF GOING
UP IN VIETNAM.
EXPERIENCING PET OR THE LUNAR
NEW YEAR.
OF US OF GOING TO POP LUNAR NEW
YEAR OR TED IS A TIME WHERE.
FAMILY GETS TOGETHER. TO EAT
BECAUSE WITHOUT THE THE HOLIDAY --
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF MEAT OR
PROTEIN ON THE DINNER TABLE.
I WITHOUT THE HOLIDAY --
KIDS WHEN GET A FEW DAYS OFF TO
ROAM THE WHOLE OF THE THE THE
ALLEY AND JUST PLAY IN THE
STREETS.
ALSO TO US AS AS AS CHILDREN IN
VIETNAM --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE LUNAR NEW
YEAR EVERY DAY BECAUSE WE GET
MEET.
WE GET MONEY.
AND WE GET TO SKIP SCHOOL.
AND AND THOSE ARE THE FUN
MEMORIES THAT I WILL ALWAYS TAKE
WITH ME.
EVERY TIME THE LUNAR NEW YEAR
COME AROUND --
I WILL NOT PLUG --
MY OF MARRIAGE STATUS LIKE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE --
BUT I DO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT MISTER DEEP.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
MR CHIU YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE REPRESENTING THE DIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE WORLD OFF
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND
AGAIN WANT TO WISH ALL OF YOU
WHETHER YOU ARE MARRIED OR
SINGLE.
THE BEST FORTUNE IN THAT THIS
YEAR THE PAGAN WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
INDUSTRY WOULD YOU LIKE CO
AUTHORS.
MEMBERS THIS FIRST ROLE BE FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
COUPLE OF THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CISCO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL --
CLOSER ALL.
THERE OUR SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED ON THE RESOLUTION AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE ITS THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
WHEN IT MOVED TO TAKE A FILE
ITEMS FOREIGN FIVE TWO BUDGET
RELATED MATTERS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR AB.
SEVENTY TWO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY TWO BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND ACTUALLY
TO THE STATE BUDGET MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
BUDGET.
MR TING.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WERE
BRING FORWARD TO MID YEAR BUDGET
AUGMENTATION BILLS WHICH WE
HEARD.
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE EARLIER --
LATE LAST WEEK.
FIRST THE AB SEVENTY TWO
PROVIDES THIRTY ONE MILLION OF
PROPERTY TAX BACK FILLS FOR MANY
OF THE COUNTIES THAT HAVE BEEN
DEVASTATED BY FIRES.
THOSE COUNTIES INCLUDE BUTTE
LAKE PLACENTA SHASTA AND
SISKIYOU.
ADDITIONALLY PRICE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FINANCE --
TO GIVE THEM THE FUNDING FOR
EMERGENCY FUNDING RELATING TO
IMMIGRATION OR HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
IT ALSO PROVIDES FIFTY MILLION
AND EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
FUNDED.
BY TWENTY MILLION FOR EMERGENCY
DRINKING WATER FUNDING THEY ALSO
LOANS THE STATE EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NETWORK ACCOUNT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THE STATE CAN GET STARTED ON
THE NEXT GENERATION NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM IT ALSO GIVES FINANCE
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS TO SPEND.
ON AUDIT IN LEGAL EXPERTISE
RELATED TO PUBLIC UTILITIES
FINANCE TO HELP PROTECT THE
STATE GIVEN THE RECENT ISSUES
WITH PGA ANY.
I AM WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON AB.
SEVENTY TWO ENGLISH TAKE MEASURE
OVER NINETY YOUR WRIST IS BIGGER
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTY
TWO THE PROPERTY TAX BACK FILL
THAT THIS ALLOWS COUNTIES THAT
WERE BADLY.
AFFECTED BY LAST YEAR'S TERRIBLE
DISASTERS IS EXTREMELY NEEDED
AND HIGHLY APPROPRIATE ALSO THIS
BILL HAS FUNDING FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
SAFE AND CLEAN DRINKING WATER I
REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER LEVINE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS --
I RISE IN SUPPORT. FOR ALL
EVERYTHING THAT'S IN THIS IS IS
PRETTY FANTASTIC THAT WERE ABLE
TO STEP UP.
THE SUPPORT OF COMMUNITIES --
WHETHER IT WAS RELATED FIRE
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS --
BUT ALSO IMMIGRATION AND ON A
TELLYOU ABOUT BUT NOT THE
EXPERIENCE I HAD ON CHRISTMAS
DAY.
MY SON AND I TRAVEL DOWN TO HI
OUR COLLEAGUES FROM SAN DIEGO
AND ORINDA.
AND WE MET WITH MIGRANTS WHO HAD
BEEN RELEASED BY ISIS AND BORDER
PROTECTION.
WHEN WE HEARD DIRECTLY ABOUT
THEIR STORIES WE WE ALSO AFTER
HAVING HEARD SO MUCH ABOUT IT
FROM OUR PRESIDENT ON THE NEWS --
BUT WHAT WE LEARNED WHEN WE WENT
THERE WAS THAT.
THIS WAS A PURELY --
TRUMP MADE CRISIS ON OUR BORDER.
AND THE FACT THAT WE CAN STEP UP
AND REALIZE AS A AS A STATE THAT
THIS IS A STATE WIDE CONCERN IS
NOT A BORDER REGION CONCERN BUT
ONE THAT IN IN IN --
NEEDS TO BRING ALL OF OUR EFFORT
TO IT IS GREAT THAT WE CAN BRING
THAT INTO OUR BUDGET
EXTRAORDINARILY PURPOSEFUL WE
TALK TO YOUNG BOYS TOO WERE
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
ARGUED -- TO
GET BACK IN TOUCH WITH THEIR MOM
FINALLY FOUND THEIR MOM AND WHEN
THEY FOUND THEIR MOM THEY SAW
HOW COLD SHE WAS.
IN THE CELL THAT SHE WAS CAPPED
BECAUSE BORDER PATROL HAD TAKEN
HER SWEATER AWAY.
THAT IS HOW PEOPLE ARE COMING
OVER OUR BORDER.
SICK ON AN UNHEALTHY IS BECAUSE
OF WHAT HAPPENS DURING THAT
PROCESS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS A VOICE FOR THEM
THAT THEY HAVE ADVOCATES THAT
THEY'VE A LEGAL --
LEGAL STANDING --
AND SUPPORT THEM.
AFTERWARD WE WALKED ACROSS THE
BORDER AND WE SAW WITH THAT
CRISIS LOOKS LIKE OVER IN
TIJUANA.
AND WE SAW THAT WHEN YEAR DELAY
WHEN YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GET
THROUGH TO CLAIM ASYLUM TO THEN
GO ON AND SEE YOUR FAMILY WHERE
YOU HAVE A PLACE TO GO.
THAT YOU'RE LEFT WITH
ESSENTIALLY NOTHING WE BROUGHT
WITH US I THINK YOU VERY VERY
MUCH THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION FOUNDATION.
HUNDREDS OF DENTAL KIDS
TOOTHBRUSHES AND TOOTHPASTE AND
FLOSS.
AND WE SAW THAT ON CHRISTMAS DAY.
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS A LUMP OF
COAL BECAME SOMETHING THAT EVERY
CHILD IN EVERY PARENTS WANTED SO
MUCH TO HAVE ONE OF THEIR OWN
FOR THEMSELVES A CLEAN
TOOTHBRUSH?
BECAUSE AFTER BEING DELAYED AT
THE BORDER THEY HAD NOTHING.
AND AND THE FACT THAT WE CAN AS
A BODY IS THE LEGISLATURE COME
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAVE A VOICE THAT THEY HAVE
STANDING THAT THEY ARE SEEN WITH.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIGNITY IN THIS
WORLD LIKE ALL OF US --
TO IS EXTRAORDINARILY MEANINGFUL
ONE THAT I'M GRATEFUL THAT I WAS
ABLE TO SHARE WITH MY SON --
MY TWELVE YEAR OLD SON AND MY
COLLEAGUES TO JOIN US THAT DAY --
BUT ALSO ONE THAT I'M GLAD THAT
OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ALSO AGREED THAT WE
CAN STAND UP ON BEHALF OF THE
MIGRANTS WHO HAVE BEEN --
IT DELAYED A IN SUCH A CARELESS
AND DANGEROUS WAY AT OUR BORDERS
THAT WE CAN TAKE CARE OF THEM
THANK YOU.
THE NAME IS LORRAINE MISTER
GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY TWO MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
REPRESENT ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
BORDER DISTRICTS.
AND I KNOW FIRST HAND A THE
PRICE THAT WE ARE PAYING BECAUSE
OF THE PRESIDENT'S ANTI
IMMIGRANT AGENDA WHICH IS LED TO
HASELY CONCEIVED COSTLY IN
HUMANE AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
POLICIES.
AT OUR NATION'S SOUTHERN BORDER.
ASYLUM SEEKING FAMILIES ARE
ARRIVING IN THE SAN DIEGO REGION
IN DESPERATE NEED OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HELP AND SUPPORT.
THEIR TRAVEL THOUSANDS OF MILES
FLEEING VIOLENCE AND SUFFERING
PERSECUTION IN THEIR HOMELANDS
IN SEARCH OF WHAT MANY OF YOU
BOUGHT YOUR FAMILIES TO THIS
COUNTRY.
ABETTER LIFE.
ONLY BE RELEASED INTO THE
COMMUNITY MY COMMUNITY WITH
NOTHING BUT THE CLOTHES ON THEIR
BACKS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ALONG WITH INCREDIBLE HARMFUL
COMPASSIONATE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE STOPPED UP IN
RECENT MONTHS TRYING TO FILL THE
GAP LEFT BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S.
ATTORNEY IT'S BACK ON OUR MIGHT
AND FAMILIES BUT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CANNOT DO THIS
ALONE AND SO MEMBERS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST FOR TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN AID. FOR THESE
FAMILIES AT THE BORDER ALONG
WITH AN FOR IMMEDIATE RELIEF
MEMBERS RIGHT NOW AS MY
COLLEAGUE HAS MENTIONED JUST
MOMENTS AGO THESE SERVICES I'M
GOING ON FOR MONTHS NOW.
THEY'VE STITCH THIS TOGETHER I
AS BEST THEY COULD RESPONDING TO
PEOPLE SHOWING UP WITH LITTLE.
NOTIFICATION DOZENS OR HUNDREDS
AT A TIME LEFT IN THE EAST
VILLAGE PART OF DOWNTOWN SAN
DIEGO MY DISTRICT THE EPICENTER
OF ARE HOMELESS CRISIS AND IT
WOULD POTENTIALLY ADDING
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS MORE
AND WE KNOW THIS WILL CONTINUE.
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE SO
THIS MONEY IS SO VERY NECESSARY
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
SAMUEL DELEGATION ALL OF US
WORKING TOGETHER TO HIGHLIGHT IN
ADVANCE THIS BECAUSE IT'S SO
NECESSARY.
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP SUPPORT
FAMILY REUNIFICATION FUND
EMERGENCY SHELTERS AND OTHER
SERVICES WITHOUT THESE PROGRAMS
THESE MIGRANTS WILL BECOME
HOMELESS IN MY COMMUNITY AND
EVENTUALLY THEY'LL COME TO YOUR
COMMUNITY SO WE MUST STEP UP.
AND HAVE BILL IN THIS GAP IT'S
SO EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
COLLEAGUES I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL ALTHOUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS ONCE
AGAIN FAILED US CALIFORNIA STEP
UP TO THE PLATE.
AND SERVE THESE FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINGS GLORIA GONZALEZ YOUR
RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IT'S GOING TO GO
THE RAPID RESPONSE NETWORK.
I WON I THINK ON THE JEWISH
FAMILY SERVICES THE ACL YEAR --
SAN DIEGO ORGANIZING PROJECT IN
MY CHURCH OUR LADY OF GUADALUPE
AT AM WITH FATHER PIPPIN WHO'S
HERE NOT DOING AN INTRODUCTION
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE US
SOMEBODY ELSE'S JOB TO DO FOR ME
TODAY -- BUT
I DO I DO WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PEOPLE IN SAN DIEGO WHO
RESPONDED TO THIS CRISIS --
WE'VE HAD A TEMPORARY SHELTER
REALLY.
IN MY DISTRICT SINCE OCTOBER IN
THE REASON WE HAVE A JUST
UNDERSTAND.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS WERE TOLD IN
THE STREETS --
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
ENDING A PROGRAM THIS IS A
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN IN PLACE
FOR YEARS AND YEARS --
AND IT'S IT'S CALLED THE SAFE
RELEASE PROGRAM WHERE BASICALLY
THESE ASYLUM SEEKERS WHO ARE
HERE LEGALLY THEY'VE BEEN FOUND
TO HAVE A CREDIBLE --
REASON TO CLAIM ASYLUM AS THEY
THEY USUALLY WORK WERE TAKEN AND
THEY'RE GIVEN AN ANKLE BRACELET
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WOULD
SEE TO IT.
THAT THEY WERE SENT TO THEIR
DESTINATION WHERE THE WHERE
THEIR SPONSOR OR THEIR FAMILY
WAS MOST OF THESE PEOPLE DO NOT
STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
MOST OF THESE FOLKS HAVE.
PLANE TICKETS ARE TRAIN TICKETS
A CAN BE PAID FOR BY BY THEIR
FAMILY BY SPONSORS BY PLACES.
AROUND THE UNITED STATES BUT YOU
CAN IMAGINE A FAMILY WHO IS WHAT
FROM GUATEMALA HERE WHO'S IN
SHORTS AND A TEE SHIRT.
IN IS LEFT.
BY BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON
THE STREETS OF SANTEE CEDAR ON
MY DISTRICT TO FIND THEIR WAY.
TO CHICAGO IN IN SUBZERO
TEMPERATURES.
THAT THAT'S WHAT BASICALLY WITH
NO EXPLANATION THESE FOLKS DON'T
EVEN SPEAK SPANISH MOST OF THE
TIME THEY SPEAK A DIALECT OF
INDIGENOUS --
GUATEMALAN.
LANGUAGES AND IT'S IT'S AMAZING
TO ME.
THAT SOMETHING THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN ABLE TO DO
FOR SO LONG WITH STOPS SO
ABRUPTLY AND LEFT SO MANY PEOPLE
IN A VULNERABLE POSITION IT
MAKES THEM VULNERABLE TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
AND IT MAKES OUR SHELTERS ARE
HOMELESS SHELTERS VULNERABLE TO
HAVING MORE PEOPLE THERE QUITE
FRANKLY BECAUSE WHAT ARE THESE
PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE A GUIDE TO
WHERE THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
GETTING SO THESE ORGANIZATIONS
IN SAN DIEGO THEY THEY STEPPED
UP THEY'VE BEEN FILLING THAT
VOID.
BUT THANK GOD WE HAVE A GOVERNOR
WHO WENT DOWN THERE TO LOOK TO
SAID WE NEED TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION THIS IS A SOLUTION THAT
ALL OF US HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR QUITE FRANKLY --
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WHAT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S RESPONSIBILITY
BUT BUT THE SCENE YOU COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ALSO PASSED
A RESOLUTION FOUND A PLACE FOR
NEW TEMPORARY SHELTER.
IN THE STATE HAS TO COME UP WITH
SOME MONEY TO ENSURE THAT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN CONTINUE TO
RUN IT THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
IT IS NOT A PERMANENT SHELTER I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CRITICISM THAT SOMEHOW WE'RE NOT
HOUSING VETERANS IN HOMELESS
FOLKS THIS IS A TEMPORARY
SHELTER PEOPLE ARE THERE. FOR
TWENTY FOUR TO SEVENTY TWO HOURS
AT THE MOST IT IS NOT A
SITUATION BY WHICH PEOPLE ARE
USING IT IS TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
THIS IS TO GET THEM FROM FROM
BEING RELEASED ON THE STREETS TO
THEIR DESTINATION OF CHOICE FOR
THIS FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
GONNA BE WELL SPENT IN THE LONG
RUN IT'S GOING TO SAVE OUR STATE
MONEY IT'S GOING TO SAVE OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MONEY IT'S
GOING TO ENSURE.
THAT PEOPLE GET WHERE THEY
BELONG IN THEY CAN HAVE THAT
HEARING FOR ASYLUM IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER AND TO GO
BACK IN YOUR COMMUNITIES IN
STATE THESE FOLKS FOR IT FOR
WHATEVER YOU FEEL ABOUT
IMMIGRATION.
THESE FOLKS ARE HERE LEGALLY
THIS IS THEIR RIGHT TO BE HERE
THIS IS NOT SOME SORT OF YOU
KNOW I I DON'T KNOW WHAT.
THE THE OTHER SIDE LIKES TO SAY
BUT BUT THEY THEY ARE HERE
LEGALLY THEY HAVE A CLAIM TO BE
HERE ILLEGALLY AND WE NEED A
SYSTEM IN A HUMANITARIAN WAY AND
THIS IS ONE STEP IN DOING THAT
SO I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE CHURCHES
INVOLVED.
AND I AM IN HELPING TO GET US TO
THIS POINT I WANT TO THANK OUR
BUDGET CHAIR FOR ACTING SO
QUICKLY WHEN WE KIND OF HAIR ON
FIRE SAID WE NEEDED THIS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE.
OF COURSE I WANT TO THANK OUR
GOVERNOR --
FOR PROPOSES WELL I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE RISK IS ALSO MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS --
I WANT TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY TWO BECAUSE OF THIS IS A
GREAT EXAMPLE OF OUR WE ARE
ACTING IMMEDIATELY.
AND EFFECTIVELY TO DEAL WITH THE
THE DEVASTATION OF THESE
WILDFIRES THAT RAVAGED OUR STATE --
AND ALSO BUT NOT ONLY REACTING
TO WHAT'S HAPPENED BUT THINKING
FORD ABOUT WHAT WE NEED TO DO --
IN THE FUTURE --
AND HOW DO WE MAKE OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFER --
LONG TERM --
AS YOU MAY HAVE HEARD IN THE IN
THE PRESENTATION THIS DOES
PROVIDE SOME SUBSTANTIAL DOLLARS
TELL BACK FILL.
TAX REVENUE --
IN THESE COMMUNITIES IF IF YOU
COULD IMAGINE A A SMALL TOWN IN
YOUR DISTRICT --
THAT'S THAT WAS COMPLETELY WIPED
OUT BY A WILDFIRE NO ONE'S
PAYING --
PROPERTY TAXES THERE ANYMORE NO
ONE'S FINE --
YOU KNOW FOOD AND AND GOODS
RESTAURANT THERE'S NO SALES TAX
DOLLARS COMING IN.
AND YET THESE GOVERNMENTS ARE
STILL THERE AND THEY'RE TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN. TO
HELP PEOPLE RECOVER AND SO.
AND YOU KNOW THIS THIS --
BUDGET BILL HELPS ENSURE THAT WE
GET THAT BACK FILL.
THIS VITALLY NEEDED FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO PUTS MONEY
INTO MUCH NEEDED.
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS THAT WE
KNOW WE NEED TO GET ON TOP OF IN
THE FUTURE. TO HELP US RESPOND
TO EMERGENCIES MORE EFFECTIVELY
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE --
IT INVEST IN NEXT GEN --
NINE ONE ONE IN MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING OUR NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM UPGRADED AND UPDATED --
SO THAT THEY CAN BE MORE
EFFECTIVE IN FUTURE.
A DISASTER SO I I I REALLY WANT
TO THINK THE BUDGET CHAIR --
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS AND THE
BUDGET STAFF WHO WHO WERE
IMMEDIATELY ON TOP OF THIS SO I
THINK THE SPEAKER --
WHO REACHED OUT TO ME --
YOU KNOW RIGHT AFTER THIS FIRE
AND SAID WE WANT TO DO WHATEVER
WE CAN.
HOW CAN WE HELP YOUR COMMUNITIES
AND IT'S NOT JUST MINE --
IT'S COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE --
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS.
THE DEVASTATION FROM THESE
WILDFIRES BUT YOU KNOW THE STAFF
THE WHO WERE RIGHT ON TOP OF IT
BEEN WORKING ON THIS --
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO I THINK THIS IS A
BIG.
STEP FOR US I SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE AND AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL FOR ALL THE HARD WORK
[inaudible]
THAT.
THIS IS WHAT'S RIGHT YOU KNOW
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS THAT WE'RE HERE
FOR EACH OTHER.
AND WE LOOK OUT FOR ALL ALL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA AND SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT WORK AND ASKED THE SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANKS GALLAGHER.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE BUDGET ON SHOOTING.
YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE
THANK YOU.
TO ALL THE COLLEAGUES WHO ECHOED
WHY THIS --
MID YEAR AUGMENTATION IS SO
IMPORTANT AND VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT WITHOUT
A RESPECT FOR US PRIVATE.
THINGS TING WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE RIGHT [inaudible]
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE'S.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB SEVENTY THREE
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY THREE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC SAFETY
MAKING A PREPARATION THEIR FOR
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
RESTRICTING IMAGEN OPEN THANK
YOU AB SEVENTY THREE IS CLEAN UP
TO TO TECHNICAL PROVISIONS IN
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ONE THAT
DIDN'T QUITE MADE IT MAKE IT
THROUGH ONE IS A STATUTORY
PROVISION TO ALLOW DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. TO ACCESS TO RESERVE IN
CASES OF THE DECLARED DISASTER.
THIS AUTHORITY SUNSET LAST MONTH
SO WE'RE ASKING FOR THE
AUTHORITY TO BE RENEWED IT ALSO
INCLUDE OR LARA MY CLARIFYING
THAT GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS LIKE
P. YOU SEE BUS INSPECTORS.
CAN ACCESS PASSENGER MANIFESTS
ON BUSES WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
THAT'S RIGHT OR NOT AB.
SEVENTY THREE A RESTING MEASURE
OF AN OLDIE MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTY THREE THIS BILL ALLOWS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. TO ACCESS THE
DISASTER RECOVERY ASSISTANCE
ACCOUNT IN THE EVENT OF A NEW IS
STATEWIDE DISASTER THIS
DISCRETION IS VERY IMPORTANT --
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT BE DONE
TIMELY AND IT DOES NOT DIMINISH
THE LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
RETROACTIVELY PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
OF THAT SPENDING FOR THAT REASON
IT'S WORTHY OF OUR SUPPORT AND I
REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU MICHELLE NOTHING SAY
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
MISTING MAKE CLOTHES IF YOU WISH.
WITH THAT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ON MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY VOTE I
SEVENTY FOUR AT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES AND AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL TO THE
SENATE.
THERE WAS WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM
REMAINING ON THIRD READING FILE.
BACK TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE THIS IS H. R..
NINE HOUSE RESOLUTION NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH RELATIVE
TO WEAR RED DAY.
SMITH YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
I RISE TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR
H. R..
NINE I RISE IN HONOR OF MY MOM
GAIL FISHER WHO DIED OF
CONGESTIVE HEART FAILURE IN
MARCH OF TWENTY FIFTEEN MY MOM
WAS A CRITICAL CARE REGISTERED
NURSE.
SHE HAS SPENT MOST OF HER
NURSING CAREER IN CARDIAC
SURGERY.
AND IN CARDIAC SURGERY RECOVERY
IN THE I SEE YOU.
WELL SHE CERTAINLY FOUND HERSELF
IN SEVERAL RISK CATEGORIES FOR
HEART DISEASE AS A LIFELONG
SMOKER.
SOMEONE WHO STRUGGLE TO MAINTAIN
A HEALTHY WEIGHT AND AS A TYPE
TWO DIABETES SUFFER WHEN SHE HAD
HER FIRST HEART ATTACK AT THE
AGE OF FORTY SEVEN EVEN AS A
CRITICAL CARE NURSE.
SHE DID NOT ACCURATELY READ HER
OWN.
LIKE MANY WOMEN EXPERIENCING A
HEART ATTACK HER PRESENTING
SYMPTOMS WERE A TYPICAL.
LEADING HER TO DELAY SEEKING
TREATMENT.
HER FIRST PARTY APART ATTACK WAS
TREATED WITH ANGIOPLASTY AN
ASSISTANT AND WAS FOLLOWED BY A
SECOND HEART ATTACK TWO YEARS
LATER.
FORTUNATELY LIFESTYLE CHANGES
AND MORE DILIGENT CARDIAC CARE
KEPT HER WITH US TWENTY MORE
YEARS.
YET A LIFETIME OF DAMAGE HAD
BEEN DONE TO HER HEART AND IT
FAILED HER AT THE AGE OF SIXTY
SEVEN WHEN SHE HAD SO MUCH MORE
LIFE TO GIVE.
THIS RESOLUTION SEEKS TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE IMPACT OF HEART
DISEASE ON WOMEN BY RECOGNIZING
THE GO RED FOR WOMEN MOVEMENT.
FEBRUARY IS AMERICAN HEART MONTH
SO WHAT IS AN IDEAL TIME TO
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE ESPECIALLY
WOMEN. TO FOCUS ON THEIR HEARTS
AND TO GET THEIR FAMILIES
FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES INVOLVED.
DISEASE IS THE NUMBER ONE KILLER
OF WOMEN.
TAKING MORE LIVES THAN ALL FORMS
OF CANCER COMBINED.
ALMOST HALF OF ALL
CARDIOVASCULAR DEATHS OCCUR IN
WOMEN.
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES KILL ONE
WOMAN ABOUT EVERY EIGHTY SECONDS.
AND YET ABOUT 80% OF
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASES CAN BE
PREVENTED.
THE STATISTICS ARE STAGGERING.
MORE THAN ONE IN THREE WOMEN IS
LIVING WITH SOME FORM OF
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE.
WHEN IT COMES TO STROKES FOUR
MILLION STROKE SURVIVORS ALIVE
TODAY ARE WOMEN?
NEARLY 60% OF STROKE DEATHS ARE
IN WOMEN.
EACH YEAR ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
THOUSAND MORE FEMALES THAN MALES
HAVE A STROKE.
WOMEN HAVE A HIGHER LIFETIME
RISK OF STROKE THAN MEN.
HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE OR
HYPERTENSION IS THE SECOND
REASON LEADING CAUSE OF
PREVENTABLE HEART DISEASE AND
STROKE DEATH SECOND ONLY TO
SMOKING.
MORE THAN 30% OF CARDIOVASCULAR
EVENTS AND WOMEN ARE DUE TO
HYPERTENSION.
MEMBERS THIS RESOLUTION IS VERY
PERSONALLY IMPORTANT TO ME.
BUT HEART DISEASE WILL TOUCH
EACH OF US AT SOME POINT.
SO THIS IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE THE TIME EACH YEAR
TO RECOGNIZE WHERE RED FOR WOMEN
DAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
THE AMERICAN STROKE ASSOCIATION
AND OTHERS HAVE WORK TO RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH AND HOW WE
CAN IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR WOMEN
AND ALL AMERICANS.
AWARENESS IS THE FIRST STEP.
KNOW YOUR NUMBERS TOTAL
CHOLESTEROL HDL THE GOOD
CHOLESTEROL BLOOD PRESSURE BLOOD
SUGAR AND BODY MASS INDEX.
TALK TO YOUR DOCTOR ABOUT WAYS
TO LOWER YOUR HEART HEALTH RISK.
MOVE MORE MAKE PHYSICALACTIVITY
A PRIORITY IN YOUR LIFE AND FOR
YOUR LOVED ONES.
IT SMART MAKE HEALTHY FOOD AND
BEVERAGE CHOICES A PART OF YOUR
LIFESTYLE.
REDUCE SODIUM INTAKE THAT ONE'S
FOR MY DAUGHTER.
LIMIT OR ELIMINATE HIGH SUGARY
DRINK CONCEPTION THAT ONCE FOR
MY OTHER DAUGHTER AND EAT MORE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT'S FOR
BOTH OF MY KIDS.
AND FINALLY MONITOR YOUR BLOOD
PRESSURE IF YOU HAVE HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE MONITOR IT REGULARLY
AND TRACK IT.
I'M IN THE GALLERY WITH US TODAY
WE ARE WELCOMING LILY ROCHA THE
OFFICIAL SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION AND A
VOLUNTEER WITH THE ASSOCIATION
FOR MANY YEARS.
AT THE AGE OF JUST THIRTY SEVEN
SHE SUFFERED A HEART ATTACK NOW
TEN YEARS AFTER THE UNEXPECTED
HEART ATTACK LEE HAS MADE HEART
HEALTH AND ADVOCACY FOR HEART
HEALTH HER PRIORITY.
I'D LIKE TO THANK HER FOR
TRAVELING TO SACRAMENTO TODAY AS
WELL AS THE OTHER AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION VOLUNTEERS ALSO IN
THE GALLERY.
I WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND COMMEND
HER AND THE REST OF THE
VOLUNTEERS FOR THEIR HARD WORK
AND DEDICATION TO THIS IMPORTANT
CAUSE.
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION IS
HOSTING A BLOOD PRESSURE AND
HEALTH SCREENING IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND I ENCOURAGE MEMBERS
AND STAFF TO DROP BY AND CHECK
THEIR BLOOD PRESSURE AND ENJOY
SOME HEART HEALTHY SNACKS AND
RECIPES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF HR.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER MISS RUBIO
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO MY MY SUPPORT
FOR HR NINE AND TO GIVE A BRIEF
SHOUT OUT TO LADY ROGER WHO IS
HERE WITH US TODAY IN THE
GALLERY.
LILY USED TO LIVE IN MY DISTRICT
AND DOES A LOT OF GREAT
VOLUNTEER WORK THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION.
AND MANY OTHER NON PROFITS HE
WILL BE RECOGNIZED ON THE SENATE
FLOOR BY SENATOR RUBIO WHO
HAPPENS TO REPRESENT MY AREA.
SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE SHE
GETS PROPER RECOGNITION IN OUR
HOUSE.
THANK YOU AGAIN THE LEAD FOR
BEING HERE TODAY AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THERE IS REALLY A DOCTOR WITH
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I'D LIKE TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA CLARITA FOR
BRINGING THIS.
TO HEAR AND IT'S GREAT TO SEE AN
AMAZING SEA OF RED HERE TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF GO
READ -- IN
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
IMPORTANT AND SHE MENTIONED THIS
IS THE IS THE SYMPTOMS ARE OFTEN
DIFFERENT FOR FOR WOMEN AND THEY
ARE FOR A MAN AND SO I JUST WANT
TO I WANT TO HIT ON THOSE
SYMPTOMS JUST SO THAT WE CAN ALL
BE AWARE OF THAT --
OBVIOUSLY PAINTING PRESSURE IN
THE CHEST IS A COMMON VERY VERY
COMMON SYMPTOM WHETHER YOU'RE
MALE OR FEMALE BUT YOU KNOW PAIN
OR DISCOMFORT IN ONE OR BOTH
ARMS COULD BE A SYMPTOM EVEN
PAIN IN YOUR JAW YOUR KNACK OR
STOMACH COULD BE A SYMPTOM.
SHORTNESS OF BREATH SOMETIMES
BREAKING OUT IN A COLD SWEAT --
NAUSEA LIGHT HEADEDNESS ALL
THESE CAN BE SYMPTOMS AND
INTERESTINGLY A LOT OF TIMES
WOMEN SUFFER.
FROM A HEART ATTACK --
WHEN THEY'RE RESTING OR EVEN AS
MIND AND ACTUALLY I'M FEELING
GUILTY BECAUSE?
I HAD YOU KNOW SALTY POTATO
CHIPS AND SALAMI AND PEANUT
BUTTER AND CRACKERS AND ALL
SORTS OF STUFF FOR LUNCH HERE
TODAY.
SO I'M GOING TO EAT THAT THE A
MANDARIN ORANGE HERE AND TRY TO
MAKE UP FOR IT THANK YOU I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS FOR THIS --
A THESE A HOUSE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WOULD.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
ON THE ITEM MISS SMITH YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH --
AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO AUTHORS ON
THE RESOLUTION.
NO CO AUTHORS.
SO WE WILL TAKE A ARE YOU SURE
ABOUT THAT
MEMBERS WE ARE WENT
OVER THE FIRST ROLE FOR CO
AUTHORS ON HR NINE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR
[inaudible]
NINE YEAH [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
OKAY.
CLOSE ALL THEIR SEVENTY CO
AUTHORS ADDED NO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALSO IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THAT RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED [inaudible]
IS.
MEMBERS WE STILL HAVE
ANNOUNCEMENTS AND ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY A FEW BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DELIVERING
HIS STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS.
NEXT TUESDAY FEBRUARY TWELFTH
FLOOR SESSION WILL CONVENE AT
TEN THIRTY AM THE JOINT
CONVENTION WILL CONVENE AT TEN
FORTY FIVE AM IN THE GOVERNOR
WILL DELIVER HIS SPEECH AT
ELEVEN AM.
THAT IS THE STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS.
WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOME.
MEMBERS TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA AS BIRTHDAY
PLEASE JOIN ME IN.
WISHING HIM A HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
MEMBERS I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WE'LL BE MEETING IN THE RULES
ROOM.
UPON A GERMAN OF SESSION TODAY
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
WILL BE MEETING IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ROOM UPON.
ADJOURNMENTS --
MEMBERS BRIEFLY BACK TO GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS ON BEHALF.
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SKIN SALAS.
AND GLORIA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN WELCOMING MS
SANDRA ALTERADO COORDINATOR OF
THE SAN DIEGO RAPID RESPONSE
NETWORK AS WELL AS REVEREND JOSE
WILKINSON PASTOR OF OUR LADY OF
GUADALUPE CHURCH IN SAN DIEGO.
THEY ARE SEATED IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE WALK. FOR THE FOR A MOVE
TO ADJOURNMENTS MEMBERS SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
TUESDAY FEBRUARY FIFTH CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY SIX
CHECK IN SESSION.
THURSDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT NINE AM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
IF YOU MUST PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS
WE HAVE ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE GRAN
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK.
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
[inaudible]
MR.
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IS WITH IMMENSE SADNESS TODAY
BUT I JOIN A MEMORY OF MY
LONGSTANDING FRIEND AND
PROMINENT PATROLLING EXECUTIVE.
TERENCE RAY INJURES.
TERRY PASSED AWAY ON JANUARY
NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN HE WAS.
SEVENTY SEVEN AFTER FOUNDING
INTERSTATE OIL COMPANY THEY
SMALL WAREHOUSE AND ONE DELIVERY
TRUCK IN OCTOBER OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY TERRY TRANSFORMS COMPANY
INTO EIGHT BRANCHES LOCATION THE
CALIFORNIA BEYOND.
PROVIDING GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES.
TERRY GENEROUSLY SHARES
EXPERTISE BE ON HIS OWN COMPANY
SERVING AS CHAIR OF PACIFIC OIL
CONFERENCE.
AND PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT --
MURATSUCHI ATION WHICH PROBABLY
REPRESENTS SMALL FAMILY IN
FORMULA MOVING FORWARD.
ALTHOUGH HE'S TREMENDOUSLY
ACTIVE IN HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE
TERRY ALSO UNDERSTOOD THE VALUE
OF SPENDING TIME WITH LOVED ONES.
DID SO ON A DAILY BASIS.
WHAT IT WAS AT THEIR HOME IN
LAKE TAHOE?
ON CAMPING EXCURSIONS SHARING
HIS PASSION FOR FISHING AND
HUNTING OR TRAPPING ABROAD TERRY
TREASURED HIS TIME WITH HIS
FAMILY.
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LAURIE.
IS CHILDREN GREG TODD AND BRENT
HIS DAUGHTER LAWS MELANIE ASHLEY
AND SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN AND
SITTING IN THE AUDIENCE THERE IS
SOME BRAND AND WIFE LORI.
HUBER MEMBERS AS DISTINGUISHED
AND CARING INDIVIDUAL WHO LIVE
LIFE TO THE FULLEST WHOSE
GENEROSITY WAS EXTENDED TO
EVERYONE.
WITHOUT EXPECTATION OF REWARD.
IN THE SPIRIT WILL LIVE FOREVER
IN THE HEARTS MEMORIES A ALL OF
HIS LOVED ONES.
MY HEART GOES OUT TO THE EDGES
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
TERRY WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADJOURN IN TERRY'S MEMORY
[inaudible]
DAVIS COOPER.
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I RISE TODAY TO GERMAN IN THE
MEMORY.
OF THE LEGENDARY SINGER NANCY
WILSON.
SHE STARTED HER CAREER WINNING A
LOCAL TALENT CONTEST AT THE AGE
OF FIFTEEN THIS WOULD BLOSSOM
INTO FIVE DECADES IN THE
SPOTLIGHT WHEN SHE RECORD OVER
SEVENTY ALBUMS.
AND ONE AT THREE GRAMMYS HER
AWARDS IN A CLAIM OR TOO MUCH TO
LIST TODAY BUT SHE WAS A TRUE
ARTIST MASTERING BLUES JAZZ ARE
IN BE POP AND SOUL.
HER TALENTS CONTINUED ON SCREEN
STARRING IN THE NANCY WILSON
SHOW WHICH ALSO WON AN EMMY.
SHE WAS ALSO AN INTERNATIONAL
STAR WITH THE SIZEABLE FAN BASE
IN JAPAN AS WELL THIS WOULD LEAD
RECORDING FIVE ALBUMS FOR
JAPANESE MUSIC PRODUCERS AND
WOULD ALSO WINNER HEARD THE
TOKYO SONG FESTIVAL.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE SINGING
MADE HER FAMOUS BUT THE IMPACT
SHE HAD ON SOCIETY ARE WHAT MADE
HER LEGENDARY.
A LEADER OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT SHE WAS INDUCTED TO THE
INTERNATIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS WALK
OF FAME IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE WHEN SHE
RECEIVED THAT AWARD SHE SAID AT
THIS AWARD MEANS MORE TO ME THAN
ANYTHING ELSE I HAVE EVER
RECEIVED.
SHE WAS A FLATTER PISTON HAD OR
THE INNER CITY YOUTH.
SINCE YOU STARTED THE NANCY
WILSON OF FOUNDATION.
AND SHE CREDITS HER RURAL
UPBRINGING TO HER SUCCESS OF
THIS FOUNDATION WAS HER WAY OF
MAKING SURE THAT CHILDREN HAVE
SOME OF THE SAME LIBERAL
EXPERIENCES THAT THAT SHE HAD.
SHE LOVED OF THE HIGH DESERT SHE
LOVES THE OPEN SPACES IN THE BIG
SKY AND WAS HONOR FOR ME TO BE
ABLE TO REPRESENT.
A HER IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY SO
TODAY MISTER SPEAKER.
I'M GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO TURN
IN HER MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER MESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF MY YOUR
FRIEND BILL AL ALEXANDER WHO IS
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA.
BILL WAS A RESIDENT OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA A LIFELONG PUBLIC
SERVANT AND A FAMILY MAN HE
MOVED RANCHO CUCAMONGA ALONG
WITH HIS FAMILY IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND WAS
ACTIVE IN THE INCORPORATION OF
THE CITY IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BILL
DEDICATED TWENTY SIX YEARS OF
HIS LIFE AS MAYOR AND COUNCIL
MEMBER TO THE CITY OF RANCHO
CUCAMONGA.
HE FIRST BEGAN HIS CAREER OF
PUBLIC SERVICE AS A FIREMAN.
A POSITION HE SIR FOR THIRTY
YEARS HE LATER BECAME A CAPTAIN
AN ARSON INVESTIGATOR FOR THE
CITY OF ONTARIO.
HE ALSO SERVED ON THE FOOT HILL
FIRE PROTECTION BOARD FOR ELEVEN
YEARS PRIOR TO HIS ELECTION TO
THE RANCHO CUCAMONGA CITY
COUNCIL IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BILL IS
SURVIVED BY HIS THREE SONS ONE
DAUGHTER SEVEN GRANDDAUGHTERS
AND TWO GREAT GRANDSONS AND ONE
GREAT GRANDDAUGHTER.
I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN AND THE
MEMORY OF MAYOR BILL --
XANDER WHO WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU MISS ROSS.
MR THIS AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I STAND TODAY TO ASK
YOU TO JOIN ME.
IN A JOINING IN THE MEMORY OF
ANITA HIRSCH.
WHO PASSED AWAY IN STUDIO CITY
ON OCTOBER TWENTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN SHE WAS EIGHTY
TWO YEARS OF AGE?
I SHE WAS CONSIDERED AN ACTIVIST
PHILANTHROPIST AND A BUSINESS
WOMAN.
I NEED A WAS MOST NOTABLY A
WOMAN OF GREAT VALOR.
ANSWER RUSSIAN REFUGEES ESCAPING
THE BOLSHEVIK REVOLUTION.
RECOGNIZING THIS PART OF HER
HISTORY INDEED ADVOCATED FOR
PERSECUTED JEWS FROM THE SOVIET
UNION IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
BY BRINGING DIPLOMATIC ATTENTION.
TO THE ISSUE AND HELPING
IMPRISONED CHOOSE EMIGRATE. TO
ISRAEL.
SHE LED THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
FIVE NURSERY SCHOOLS FOR
UNDERSERVED FAMILIES IN TEL AVIV.
AND SHE ALSO FOUNDED IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT CENTER IN
JAVA. TO PROMOTE COEXISTENCE
BETWEEN JEWS AND ARABS.
I NEED AND HER LATE HUSBAND.
STANLEY SUPPORTED JEWISH FAMILY
SERVICES BY BUILDING A KOSHER
KITCHEN TO SERVE THOUSANDS OF
NEEDY ANGELENOS AND HELPING WITH
THE CONSTRUCTION.
OF A FLAGSHIP SOCIAL SERVICES
LOW AFFECTS BOULEVARD.
I NEED A LOVE LOS ANGELES AND
GIVE BACK TO IT IN MANY WAYS.
SHE HELPED DEVELOP A HABITAT
WALK IN THE LA RIVER GREENWAY
TRAIL WHICH IS USED BY MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT AS WELL AS LOS ANGELES
LOS ANGELENOS.
SHE ALSO ESTABLISHED THE FIRST
ENDOWMENT FUND TO SUPPORT
SCHOLARSHIPS WITH THE OAKWOOD
SCHOOL.
A PRIVATE SCHOOL IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
I NEED A WAS DEVOTED TO MAKING
SURE MORE STUDENTS COULD ACCESS
AGREED EDUCATION.
THERE WAS MUCH MORE TERNYATA
THAN HER ASTONISHING GENEROSITY.
SHE WAS A DEEPLY ETHICAL PERSON
WITH A QUICK WIT AND A SHARP BY.
OVERALL SHE WAS A COMMITTED
ACTIVIST FOR THOSE LESS
FORTUNATE THAN HERSELF.
MY THOUGHTS REMAIN WITH HER FOUR
CHILDREN STEVEN ADAM ELIZABETH
AND JENNIFER.
ALONG WITH HER FIVE
GRANDCHILDREN THALIA NOAH ERIN
EATEN AND KOBE.
I'M SURE ANY THIS FAMILY WILL
CONTINUE HER WONDERFUL LEGACY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER NAZARIAN.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR A GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF ESALEN WHEN SHAW
HILFENHAUS.
A CONSTITUENT OF MINE FROM SANTA
CLARITA WHO PASSED AWAY JANUARY
TWENTY FIRST AFTER A LENGTHY
BATTLE WITH PANCREATIC CANCER.
LYNN SHAW GREW UP AS AN ACTIVIST.
SHE WAS THE ONLY DAUGHTER OF A
UNION CARPENTER AND A UNION
ORGANIZER.
IT'S HAD HER ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL EVEN AS A CHILD WALKING
PRECINCTS AND MAKING PHONE CALLS.
SHE WAS A LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR
SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES FROM
EXPANDED CHILD CARE TO EXPANDED
HEALTH CARE.
SHE WORK FOR TI ERA DEL SOL A
NONPROFIT FOUNDATION SERVING
ADULTS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
WHEN CONTINUED SERVICE TO THE
DISABILITY COMMUNITY WITH HER
WORK FOR FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LLOYD LEVIN?
AND LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER BOB LIMóN FAILED.
NGUYEN ADVOCATED FOR MANY ISSUES
INCLUDING SUPPORT FOR A LIVABLE
WAGE SUPPORT FOR HOME HEALTH
CARE WORKERS.
SHE SPOKE OUT AGAINST SCHOOL
VOUCHERS AND PROP.
TWO TWO SIX SHE SERVED ON THE
CAMPAIGN FOR ECONOMIC DEMOCRACY
AND CHILD CARE COMMISSION.
SHE WAS ON THE STEERING
COMMITTEE FOR PROP ONE EIGHTY
SIX THE SINGLE PAYER INITIATIVE
AND HAS CONTINUED THAT WORK WITH
HER SUPPORT OF LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE.
SHE WORKED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION BILL OF
RIGHTS.
SHE SPOKE BEFORE THE LOS ANGELES
CITY COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF EQUAL
PAY FOR WOMEN.
SHE WORKED WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AND NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA TO DEFEAT THE THREE
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION
INITIATIVES.
SHE'S HELD MULTIPLE POSITIONS
WITHIN OUR STATE'S DEMOCRATIC
PARTY INCLUDING CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
PLATFORM COMMITTEE.
SHE WAS THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HAVING SERVED LONGER THAN ANY
OTHER CHAIR.
FORMER VICE CHAIR OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
FOUNDING PRESIDENT OF DEMOCRATIC
WOMEN OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND A GRADUATE OF THE VALLEY
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE.
WHEN WAS ONCE THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE FOR THE SEAT I AM NOW
PRIVILEGE TO HOLD?
WHEN WAS A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY SHE
LIVED IN SANTA CLARITA WITH HER
HUSBAND JIM HEALTH AND HOUSE AND
HER TWO DOGS OTIS AND LILY?
LYNN LITERALLY GAVE EVERY LAST
MOMENT OF HER LIFE TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUSES AND THE THINGS
SHE BELIEVED IN.
SHE DELIVERED MY CAMPAIGN SIGNS
RIGHT UP UNTIL ELECTION NIGHT.
IT IS VERY SAD THAT WE'VE LOST
HER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN THE MEMORY
OF ONE SHOT.
MS REVERSE YOUR ALSO RECOGNIZE
ON THIS A GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA CLARITA FOR LEADING THIS
ADJOURNMENT.
I ALSO RISE TO RECOGNIZE THE
LIFE OF LYNN SHAW WHO WAS A
LIFELONG RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT
PRIOR TO MOVING --
TO THE THIRTY EIGHTH DISTRICT IN
THIS -- AND
SHE ALSO WORKED IN THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY FOR MANY YEARS.
THOSE WHO HAVE HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WERE OFTEN ASK THEMSELVES
WHAT WOODLAND DO.
I'M NOT SURE IF I'VE MASTERED
HOW TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION JUST
YET.
BUT I CAN DEFINITELY TELL YOU
WHAT SHE HAS DONE.
FROM AN EARLY AGE THE IMPORTANCE
OF PUBLIC SERVICE WAS INSTILLED
IN HER AS WELL AS THE IMPORTANCE
OF STANDING UP FOR VOLVO PEOPLE.
AND THOSE LESS FORTUNATE LINK
GRADUATED FROM LA MISSION
COLLEGE AND SO MARK WORKING IN
COMMERCE BEFORE BEFORE FINDING
HER CALLING IN POLITICS.
HER INTEREST IN POLITICS LED HER
TO EXTENSIVE INVOLVEMENT IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE WAS A MEMBER OF NUMEROUS
DEMOCRATIC CLUBS STARTED A FEW
HERSELF SERVED ON THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY OF THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND HELP MANY LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS FOR MANY YEARS.
SHE LATER SERVED AS THE CHAIR OF
THE DISABILITIES CAUCUS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND THE LONGEST SERVING CHAIR IN
HISTORY OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
SHE ALSO MET HER HAS JIM WHILE
INVOLVED WITH THE PARTY AND
MARRIED HIM AT THE TWO THOUSAND
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN LYNN RECEIVE
THE NORTH LA COUNTY REGIONAL
CENTER COMMUNITY SERVICE AWARD
FOR HER LIFETIME OF SERVICE AS
WELL THE LA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
ON A VIRA ROBERTO AWARD GIVEN TO
ONLY ONE DEMOCRAT PER YEAR.
FROM ENSURING A BETTER FUTURE
FOR PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. TO BEING A
LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN'S
RIGHTS LYNN SEAN MADE AN
INDELIBLE IMPACT ON THIS
COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU LYNN FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE AND FOR LEADING THE NEXT
GENERATION WITH THE TOOLS TO
ANSWER WHAT WOODLAND DO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER BASS THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DEATHS OF THE PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RICHARD IN
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN A MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED.
SEEING HEARING OF FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOST.
MR BONTA MOVES MISTER MAYES
SECONDS.
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY FEBRUARY SEVENTH.
AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED